in this video we'll talk about
ulcerative colitis this is a highly
topic for USMLE step one
ulcerative colitis is a chronic
inflammatory bowel disease of unknown
etiology which affects the colon and the
rectum it's important to note that the
large intestine the colon is actually
affected the other portion of the
intestine or the GI tract is not
affected in this disease so here is the
rectum colon cecum and the disease
starts or spreads from the rectum and
goes all the way to the cecum and there
is inflammation associated with this
disease if we look at the cross section
we can appreciate that the mucosal
lining is highly inflamed and eroded
there are flares there are times where
the disease flare up and there are times
when there is recovery and remission
ulcerative colitis is different from
Crohn's disease because in Crohn's
disease any part of the GI tract can be
affected but in ulcerative colitis
selectively the colon and the rectum is
affected
let's talk about the geographic
distribution this particular disease is
highly prevalent in U.S Australian
population and also in some part of the
Asian population so already we can
understand there is a genetic
predisposition which increase the risk
of disease
but it's not well characterized or well
understood yet
the symptoms involve
persistent diarrhea rectal bleeding
bloody stool weight loss in severe cases
abdominal cramps or pain fatigue Etc
now this kind of spectrum of symptoms
can be variable so there are situations
known as proctitis in this case there is
a inflammation in the rectum and the
only symptom is kind of rectal bleeding
and blood is stool there are situation
known as proctosigmoidities in this case
inflammation involves the rectum and the
sigmoid colon
and the symptoms involved bloody
diarrhea abdominal cramps and pain
inability to move bowel even if you have
a strong urge to do so there are other
severe cases like distal colitis and
extensive colitis in this case rectum
sigmoid colon and descending portion of
the colon so a vast majority of the
colon is affected so the symptoms would
be kind of similar like bloody diarrhea
abdominal cramping on the left side
specifically
there is a urgency to
defecate but you don't have you can't do
it because there is a problem problem in
the bowel movement
and the last thing is pancolitis where
entire colon is actually affected and
it's most severe from form and leads to
severe abdominal cramp fatigue and
significant weight loss
now let's talk about the Immunology of
ulcerative colitis
so now we are looking at a portion of
the colon and in the left side you can
see the normal one and the right side
it's ulcerative colitis already you can
see in ulcerative colitis the intestinal
epithelial cells are affected the tight
junctions between them are affected and
inflamed so the intestinal barrier is
breached the first thing that comes in
our mind when it when we talk about a
large intestine is the mucous secreted
by these cells so in this case a thick
layer of mucine could be found on the
intestinal epithelial cells
and also there are gut microbiome in the
Pres in the colon
so these aspects are disrupted in
ulcerative colitis first of all there is
a reduction in mucine production so the
mucine layer becomes thin that makes the
bowel movement harder
and also the heterogeneity of the gut
microbiota is reduced only a specific
type of bacteria is now prevalent in
this situation so alteration in the gut
microbiota composition is a significant
uh biological phenomenon associated with
ulcerative colitis then this bacteria
can
enter
the mucosal layer which can ultimately
trigger inflammatory responses and that
makes it so painful
so once the bacteria invades then there
are immune cells such as neutrophils
which try to engulf the bacteria and
eliminate these threats but neutrophil
attracts many other cells macrophages
and dendritic cells together these cells
which are phagocytotic produce several
cytokines such as
interleukin-1223 tnf and interleukin-6
all of these are broadly classified as
inflammatory cytokines
they trigger some of them triggered the
differentiation of T helper cell into
th1 subpopulation now th one
subpopulation is also another
subpopulation which give rise to
interferon gamma and tnf
so overall
vast majority of the cytokines that are
produced in this case of disease is
basically pro-inflammatory cytokines as
a result what happens is there is a
strong inflammation and a more
attraction of monocytes and neutrophil
to the site of infection so overall the
inflammation increases in this
particular disease
now there are not only inflammatory
cells present in our immune system there
are some variation of T cells known as
regulatory T cell that can balance out
the inflammatory effect of th1
subpopulation of cells so there is
always a balance between
anti-inflammatory and pro-inflammatory
cytokine and the the inflammatory and
anti-inflammatory cells but in case of
uh
ulcerative colitis the balance is tipped
off the pro-inflammatory cytokines and
the cells that produce pro-inflammatory
cytokines they increases in number
whereas the cells that produce
anti-inflammatory cytokines such as
deregulatory cells their number has been
decreased this is the latest research
that came out
then histology of the ulcerative colitis
endoscopic examination can give us an
idea about the ulcerative colitis and
from the biopsy sample if histology is
performed a normal colon would look like
this nice scripts and cells are nicely
aligned
in ulcerative colitis The prominent
features are Crypt at trophy also
absence or loss of Crypt and in some
cases
abnormal branching of the crypt
and here is the histology one can
clearly appreciate the dramatic
difference in the histology the crypts
are almost lost in the right hand case
so Distortion basal plasma or
cytosis epithelial metaplasia goblet
cell depletion are the prominent
histological features associated with
ulcerative colitis
then endoscopic findings also include
many important aspect so if you look at
the mild ulcerative colitis versus
severe ulcerative colitis you can
clearly appreciate the reddish and the
inflamed
region in the colon right
so endoscopic observation can lead can
give rise to several kind of observation
like obliterated vascular pattern that
is found in mild to severe forms of this
disease mucosal fibrillarity and
erythema bleeding erosion of erosion and
ulceration
treatment options include antibiotics
because it is thought that many k in in
many cases these bacteria can cause this
disease though there is an autoimmune
angle to it so it's still not clear what
is the disease etiology so antibiotics
are used to treat the bacteria excess
bacterial in infection which causes the
inflammation
then steroids can be used in severe
cases where the immune system is
hyperactive and too much inflammation is
taking place then there could be
cytokine therapy anti-tnf or
anti-inflammatory cytokine therapy to
bring down the inflammatory effect and
lastly the last result is to do removal
with surgery so specific surgical
operations are performed but that's the
last result so I hope this video was
useful if you like this video give it a
big thumbs up don't forget to like share
and subscribe follow us on Instagram and
Facebook we can get more notes and flash
cards links are provided in description
you can support our Channel using super
thanks you can pay via paytm PayPal or
UPI see you in next video
foreign